[Music]
did you know that your body is designed
to live 120 years that most chronic and
degenerative diseases are preventable
with the proper nutrition the
information in this tape will change the
way you presently view nutrition you'll
learn about the vital role that minerals
play in enhancing Your vitality and
promoting
longevity known as the mineral doctor Dr
Joel wallik is considered an expert on
major and trace minerals and mineral
deficiency diseases he first discovered
the importance of nutrition as a
veterinarian where he had great results
treating animals with the obvious
principle of Health through nutrition he
had always been bewildered that this
simple concept was not a common practice
of the medical profession Dr wallet
became determined to apply this Common
Sense approach to humans so after
earning his third degree in naturopathic
medicine he began a unique Family
Practice in Oregon fueled by his strong
belief that our genetic potential for
longevity is 120 to 140 years Dr Ric has
made a major impact on the field of
alternative medicine he's had over 70
articles in nutrition and pharmaceutical
research published been nominated for a
Nobel Prize in medicine and appeared on
several local and network television
shows including 2020 he also hosts his
own weekly radio talk show called let's
play doctor known as The Rush Limba of
alternative medicine let's join Dr
Wallock at a recent live
seminar well I'm certainly glad you're
here how many of you grew up on a farm
or still work a farm or have anything to
do with livestock I'll tell you what
you're my kind of people because I grew
up on a farm in West St Louis County
back in the 50s and we start out with
beef calves and uh if if you raise
livestock the only way it can make money
is if you raise a lot of your own feed
for those of you don't have that
experience and so we raised our own corn
and we raised our own soybeans and our
own hay and we had a truck come out from
the mill and this truck would come out
from the mill and it would grind up the
corn and the soybeans and the hay and
then we would add sacks of vitamins min
minerals trace minerals and we'd make
pellets out of it and this is what we
would feed the calves in 6 months time
we'd ship them to Market to be
slaughtered we'd save back some of the
best ones for ourself we'd knock them in
the head and eat them put it bluntly and
um it always fascinated me as a teenager
that we did that for those Cales and in
six months ship them off to be
slaughtered or we' eat them and we
wanted to live to be 100 years of age
without any aches and pains and guess
what we didn't take any vitamins or
minerals and that bothered me so I asked
my dad I'd say hey Pops how come you do
that for those Cavs you don't do that
for us and he'd give me this good old
Missouri farm wisdom he'd say things
like shut up boy you're getting this
farm fresh food and we hope you
appreciate it and of course I was very
quiet then because I didn't want to miss
out on any meals well then when I went
to school I went to the University of
Missouri the um uh School of Agriculture
and I got my degree in agriculture and
it was very interesting to me that uh I
got my major in animal husbandry and
nutrition my minor was in field crops
and soils and then I got into veterinary
school as a freshman Veterinary student
I learned the answer to my
question we know how to prevent and cure
diseases in animals with nutrition and
the reason why we do that is because we
don't have major medical we don't have
hospitalization Blue Cross Blue Shield
we don't have um
Medicare we don't have Hillary to watch
out for
us if you're going to make money as a
farmer you better know to do stuff
yourself and you better uh do it
efficiently with feed and nutrition if
you can well to make a long story short
after I got out of veterinary school I
went to Africa for two years and I was
able to fulfill a Boyhood dream I was
able to be a Frank Buck for two years
and work with Marlon Perkins many of you
remember him from the Mutual of Omaha's
Wild Kingdom and he's a great gentleman
and after two years of working with
elephants and rhino people used to ask
me or are you a small animal vet or a
large animal vet well I tell them I'm a
extra large animal vet CU I worked with
elephants and rhinos well after two
years he sent me a telegram and said
would you come back to the St Louis Zoo
and work with us we need a Wilde
veterinarian at the zoo for a special
project we're given a $7.5 million Grant
from the um National Institutes of
Health and what we need is a
veterinarian who will do autopsies of
animals that die of natural causes in
the zoo I was just Overjoyed to do that
and so I came back and and did that and
of course I not only did autopsies for
animals that died in the St Louis Zoo
but the brookfields Zoo in Chicago the
Bron zoo in New York the National Zoo
the LA Zoo and so forth and my job again
was to do autopsies of animals that died
of natural causes in the zoo and look
for a species of animals that was Ultra
sensitive to pollution this because
during the early 60s we had just learned
about pollution and ecological problems
and disasters and nobody quite knew what
to do and so I was supposed to find a
species of animals that was extra
sensitive to this and use them much like
we did the canaries in the mine you know
the old coal miners used to put a canary
in a little wicker cage and take it down
in the mine and if methane gas or carbon
monoxide would leak into the mine the
canary would drop off the perch and die
first and the men knew to get out before
the mine blew up or they
suffocated well again to make a long
story short uh over a period of some 12
years I did
17,500 autopsies and over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 human beings who lived
in close proximity to zoos and the thing
that I found found out was this every
animal and every human being who dies of
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency and that fascinated me it
went back took me back to those calves I
said Gee that's fascinating everybody's
dying of nutritional deficiencies and we
could document this at autopsy both
chemically and biochemically and so
forth and things you saw with the eye at
the autopsy table well that fascinated
me and I wrote 75 scientific articles I
wrote uh eight multi-authored textbooks
and one textbook of my own cost 140
bucks for medical students and I'm sure
the only thing they do is use them for
door
stops and it couldn't get anybody
excited I was on
2020 uh I was on 1700
newspapers I was in magazines I was in
every new network TV that you can think
of and guess what couldn't get anybody
excited back in the 60s about
nutrition so what I did was went back to
school and became a physician to use
everything I had learned in veterinary
school about nutrition and my human
patients
and to no surprise to me it worked spent
12 years up in Portland Oregon in
general practice and um it was very
fascinating what I'm going to share with
you tonight is what I learned over those
10 12 years using nutrition with my
human patients and if you take home only
10% if you take home only 10% it will
save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery it will save you a
Gob of money and those of you in
Missouri know what that means a go means
a
lot and will save you and fact it will
add on on many healthful years to your
life okay it'll add many healthful years
to your life well you can't do this you
can't get these healthful years you
can't have longevity you can't live to
your genetic potential just falling off
the stump uh you have to do some things
and the first thing I have to do is
convince you that it is worth doing
these things I'm going to start out by
convincing you that the genetic
potential for human beings is 120 to 140
years our genetic potential for
longevity okay 120 40 years there's no
less than five cultures whose people
live to be 120 to 140 starts out in the
Tibetans in western China uh these
people were popularized back in
1934 um by James Hilton he wrote a book
called The Lost Horizon many of you
remember reading that was a puler prize
winning book way back then and they did
a movie of that in 1937 it's a very long
movie about three hours you can get it
from any Blockbuster Video and I would
encourage you to get it and look at it
when you have 3 hours it's a great movie
and the oldest living person that has
some documentation I'm sure there's a
certain amount of exaggeration in there
but there is some documentation was a
fellow a Dr Lee Li uh from China along
this Tibetan border and this fellow and
when he was 150 years old quote unquote
received a um big certificate from the
Imperial Chinese government uh he was
born in
1677 150 years later he was given a
certificate by the Imperial Chinese
government for being 150 years and then
when he got to be 200 years they sent
him another 50 years later they sent him
another certificate and supposedly he
died at age 256 and as people of that
nature he was written up in the New York
Times in 1933 when he died in the London
times and so this is fairly well
documented but he may have only been 200
years old I don't know if he was 256 but
this is the um person that led James
Hilton to write that story then uh
there's in
1967 or 68 there was a remake of that
movie it was a color version if you
haven't seen that was called shangra La
I'd urge you to see that then in eastern
Pakistan there's a group of people
called the hunzas and these people are
very famous for longevity 120 140 if
you've been in Alternative Health for
any length of time You' heard their name
at least then in what is now Western
Russia it used to be the Soviet Union
the Russian Georgians were made famous
during the 70s by Dan and yogurt you
remember the old Crimea War U veterans
they get their uniform on they'd hold a
saber up and they would get a cup of Dan
and yogurt and smile a lot and you're
were supposed to make the mental leap
that it was the Dan and yogurt that made
them live to be 120 then just south of
them the Armenians the aians and the
azer Banis are famous at least in in the
Soviet Union they were studied for some
60 years because they routinely live to
be 120 to 140 in fact in 19 uh 7 3 the
January issue of the 19 of the um um
National Geographic 1973 January
National Geographic did a special
article on people who Liv to be 100 and
are older and they featured these people
and there's a great pictorial article
you know National Geographic is very
good about coming out with pictures and
three of these dozens of pictures that
were in that article I remember one of
them was a lady who was 136 years old
she was sitting in a wicker chair with a
big Cuban cigar in one hand and an 8 oun
glass of vodka in the other and she was
partying she was having a good time she
was not in a nursing home all slouched
over and and you know ready to have
somebody take another 2500 bucks out of
her checking account uh she was enjoying
herself at 136 then there was a
semicircle of couples boy girl boy girl
boy girl and they were celebrating their
100th and 115th and 120th wedding
anniversaries then the third picture
that I remember is a gentleman who is
picking tea leaves up at the timber line
in the Caucasus Mountains in Armenia and
and um he was listening to a one of
these little transistor radios back then
and according to his birth records and
and baptismal records his military
records and the birth records of his
children uh the National Geographic said
that he was 167 years of age and the
oldest living person at that time in the
Western Hemisphere the vilcabamba
Indians in Ecuador are very famous they
live in the Andes and then in
Southeastern Peru my favorites the titty
kakas I just like them because I like
the name they're sort of east of the
Machu Picchu uh the old Community the
titty kakas live around Lake titty Kaka
and of course they're very famous for
living to be 120 to 140 well in May 11th
just about a month ago the oldest living
American at this time and documented
through the Guinness World Book of
Records was Margaret ski she was from
Radford Virginia she died at age
115 and she died of a nutritional
deficiency you can tell that from her
her obituary now she died of the
complications of a fall what did she die
from osteoporosis very good she died of
a Calcium deficiency she had no heart
disease no cancer no diabetes no other
infirmities but she died three weeks
after a fall because she didn't have
enough calcium very interesting also her
daughter said that she had a craving for
sweets until she died and that's a
disease called Pica we'll talk about
that in a little bit but usually when
you have a craving for chocolate if
you're a chocaholic or a sugarholic that
means that you have a deficiency of
chromium and vadium and we'll talk about
that in a minute then in a third world
country in Niger in Africa a chief by
the name of Bower at age 126 was
eulogized by one of his wives so I
assume it was plural it had many wives
and she was bragging about him at his
death at age 126 he was still in
possession of all his own
teeth okay so you assume that other
faculties are working
too then here's a gentleman uh from
Syria at age 13 3 he died in July of
1993 and he was in the gness World Book
of Records not because he was 133
there's been many people Liv longer than
that um not because he remarried for the
fourth time at age 80 but because
heathered nine children after the age of
80 and this meant if you add up nine
months for each child and a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children he was
still fathering children after age of a
100 and that's what got him into the
Guinness World Book of Records so
there's still hope for you fellas
[Music]
then those of you who like science um in
November of
1993 those six biospherians came out of
that dome in Arizona they were in there
for two years um three couples and they
were supposed to eat the perfect food
and recycle the atmosphere and grow
their own food and whatnot and have no
pollution in their water or air or food
and when they came out they were
examined by medical gerontologists from
uccla University of California Los
Angeles and uh they put all this
information their physical their blood
work and so forth into the medical
computers at UCLA and the medical
computer said that and projected that
they could live to be 165 years old if
they continued to do what they were
doing so all of that just says to you
that there's a there's a possibility you
can live to be 120 to 140 and when I
grew up on the farm we could grow 200
bushels of corn per acre and with all
the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did you could make a
profit if you grew 200 bushels per acre
but if you only got a 100 bushels per
acre and put out that same same effort
and the same fertilizer cost you'd lose
money and so I want you to think about
it the average lifespan for an American
today is
75.5 the average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is 58 you want to gain 20 years
statistically just don't go to medical
school you want to live to be 120 140
there's only two basic things real
simple two things to remember number one
you have to avoid the pitfalls you have
to not step on the landmines I call it
and those of you in the military you
know what that means um you do something
stupid like step on one of those things
you kill yourself wastefully or
unnecessarily and of course if you play
Russian Roulette or smoke excessively or
drink excessively or wear a black
sweatsuit and run down the middle of the
highway at 2:00 in the morning you're
going to get struck by a car uh all of
those things are fool hearty but it's
amazing how many tens of thousands of
people die in America from doing those
stupid things every year the last thing
I will share with you on that subject of
avoiding the landmines I'd suggest very
strongly to you that you avoid going to
doctors and I'm going to back up that
statement which is a pretty strong
statement with a um statement from Ralph
nater group in January of
1993 just about a year and a half ago uh
January 13th he put out a news release
based on a three-year study on the
causes of death in American hospitals
and it was 1500 page report this
three-year study and I'm not going to
waste your time or Mine by going over
the whole thing word for word but the
bottom line says a lot the bottom line
says a lot and here it is quote this is
from Ralph nater now he's a consumer
advocat advocate for those of you who
don't know him who watches out for us
quote 300,000 Americans are killed each
year in hospitals alone as a result of
medical negligence unquote I'm going to
read that figure again because it's a
huge figure quote 300,000 Americans are
killed each year in hospitals alone as a
result of medical negligence unquote he
didn't say Slipped Away quietly out of
neglect in a corner somewhere while
they're waiting for an x-ray he used the
word killed when you use the word killed
that means there was a procedure the
doctor was doing went wrong somehow that
means that they gave them a wrong
prescription they put a decimal point in
the wrong spot and gave them an
incorrect dosage these people were
killed 300,000 to appreciate how big a
figure that is you have to compare that
with our military losses in Vietnam over
10 years where we lost 56,000 people
over 10 years or an average of only
5,600 a year a field of battle where
people had guns and artillery and
explosives trying to kill each other and
millions of people poured out into the
streets and protested that war we had
political Anarchy in the last three
years of the war U students took over
universities and colleges with guns and
explosives National Guardsman shot
students at Kent State in Ohio we chased
a president out of the presidency for
5,600 military personnel a year and
here's one profession that takes your
tax money in the form of Medicare and
Medicaid and kills three 300,000 of us a
year according to Ralph nater and I
believe him he has no ax to grme and you
can go out in the street any day of the
week in any City and there isn't even a
crazy Street Preacher out there with a
sign that says protect us from
doctors I want you to think about that
folks that's number one you have to
avoid stepping on the landmine so
there's a certain value in treating
yourself when you can or preventing
disease so you don't have to get treated
now the second thing you have to do
number two is you have to do the
positive things you have to do the
positive things and I'm going to
start out here by just putting a figure
up on the board it's the number 90 and
you need 90 nutrients in your diet every
day you need 60
minerals you need 16
vitamins you need 12 essential amino
acids or protein building blocks and you
need three essential fatty acids you
need 90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're going to get a
deficiency disease if you don't have
them in complete numbers and optimal
amounts well I can tell you that I was
one of those nerds back when I was in
college I had a clipboard we didn't have
computers back then so I had a clipboard
and I I was one of those funny guys with
glasses and would walk up and down in
the Student Union there in Columbia and
say uh do you take vitamins and minerals
I was still fascinated by that and and
of course people kind of look at you
crazy and say well yeah I take vitamin E
I'd wait for him to come up with the
other 89 and they didn't they just oh I
take vitamin E well today if you ask
people do you take food supplements they
say oh yeah I take
Tums because that's what you know they
hear all the time well again you need 90
nutrients if you're going to make it but
the newspapers know and the magazines
and TV and radio knows that we're
interested in Health and Longevity and
and supplements so they all talk to us
not because the medical profession has
asked them to do that in their stad the
medical profession doesn't say hey we're
so busy saving people with surgery and
chemo theapy and radiation and
pharmaceuticals would you please educate
the people on nutrition they do it
because it sells newspapers
well my favorite article of all time
appeared in Time Magazine April 6th 1992
and if you haven't read it I'd urge you
to get it out of a school library or
public library and photocopy it stick
one copy on the door in the bathroom and
one on the refrigerator it's a cover
article it says the real power of
vitamins new research shows they may
help fight cancer heart disease and the
ravages of Aging again there's six
positive pages in here there's only one
negative sentence and was issued by a
medical doctor who was asked by the
writer of the article what do you think
what do you think about vitamins and
minerals for people as food supplements
and here's what the doctor said quote
popping vitamins doesn't do you any good
sniffs Dr Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount siai
medical school we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote well to give you a
Missouri translation of that that means
you're just peeing away your dollars if
you take vitamins and minerals you might
as well W up your dollars and throw them
in the toilet and flush them away cuz
you're not getting any redeeming value
from it those quacks are just taking
your money for those vitamins and
minerals that's what he was trying to
say got published so it must be true
right I'll tell you what after having
done those 17,500 autopsies and 454
species of animals from around the world
and 3,000 humans and liking to be
healthy myself and having children and
grandchildren and not too distant future
great-grandchildren I'd rather pee out
50 cents or a dollar a day worth of
excess vitamins and minerals is pretty
cheap insurance because if you don't
invest in yourself to the tune of a buck
a day for vitamins and minerals guess
what you're going to invest in the
lifestyle of an MD somewhere because
when you pay the medical doctor your fee
for going to see him not one penny of
that goes to study how to diagnose or
treat or prevent a catastrophic disease
in a little child like who was in here
earlier or how to prevent or diagnose or
treat better breast cancer prostate
cancer and
adults guess what that money goes for
pays the doctors's more mortgage makes
his Mercedes payment it pays a tuition
for his kids to go to medical school at
havit you know what havit is up in
Baston pays a tuition for his kids to go
to law school at Yale I believe because
we've made doctors wealthy between 1776
and the second world war the US
government spent $80 million on
Healthcare and healthc Care research and
studies right now we're at
$1.2 trillion a year for health
Healthcare and it's free we all know
it's free
right I like that lady she says like
heck it's not free but we're supposed to
believe it's free and everybody wants
more of it and more free stuff I'll tell
you what if we used a human type medical
system for the agricultural industry and
the livestock your hamburger cost $275 a
pound on the other hand if you use the
agricultural health system that we use
in animals for humans your monthly
insurance premiums for a family 5 would
be $10 a month you take your choice well
I believe since we've made them wealthy
through Insurance programs and
government subsidies I believe they owe
us something I believe they owe us at
least as much as the uh Industries do
according to for instance recall notices
this was started of course I don't know
25 years ago when Ralph nater learned
that the Ford Motor Company had made a
pinto car with a rear-end gas tank that
would blow up when you got hit from
behind at 20 mph fry everybody in the
car and when people complained to Ford
Motor Company they said well you're just
dumb for getting in a car accident we're
not going to pay you for that Ralph
nater says no it's a faulty design so he
went to a federal court and the judge
agreed with him and through a court
order forced Ford Motor Company to send
everybody a uh recall notice with a
registered letter bring that car in and
they'll fix it for nothing but they kill
300,000 a year and nobody protests as
long as we get ours free and that scares
me that attitude at any rate I've got a
bunch of these recall notices you should
have gotten over the last couple years
we'll go through them quickly number one
is ulcers how many of you ever heard
that ulcers is caused by
stress okay everybody's heard that if
you don't raise your hand you got
Alzheimer's or your fibon
right well we knew 50 years ago in in
the veterinary industry that uh ulcers
at least in pigs was caused by bacteria
called helicobacter pylori and of course
we couldn't get one of these high priced
stomach surgeons from Mayo Clinic in
fact we always used to yell hold the
Mayo when they say stuff like that and
um otherwise your pork chops would be
$275 a pound to pay for that kind of
surgery and we learned that with a trace
mineral called bismuth and the
tetracycline antibiotic that we could
prevent and and cure those stomach
ulcers and pigs without surgery and so
that's what we did cost five bucks to
cure a pig of stomach ulcers with
bismuth the trace mineral and
tetracycline well the National
Institutes of Health now not the
national Inquirer but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February of this year February 1994 and
said ulcers are caused by a bacteria
called helicobactor pylori not stress
and they can be cured they actually use
the Cure word in this news release
medical researchers never do that they
always say it shows promising results or
may be beneficial they use the Cure word
National Institutes of Health and they
say can be cured with a combination of
the trace mineral bismuth and Tetra
cycling well for those of you who don't
know what bismo comes in you can get it
from any grocery store or drugstore it's
pink about 295 for an 8 oz bottle and
it's called Pepto Bismol so a teaspoon a
day full of Pepto bismo some R calf
scour pellets you can take care of
ulcers now you have your choice where
you're going to treat your own for five
bucks or go get Whitted on that's your
choice then what's the number two cause
of death in Americans terrible disease
called cancer right now when doctors get
information on cancer you'd think they'd
photocopy that and when they send you
that bill they should send you some
photocopies of this stuff well in
September of 1993 the um National Cancer
in intitute not the national Inquirer
but the National Cancer Institute and
the um havid Medical School up in Baston
did a study on cancer patients and they
came out and they said an anti-cancer
diet was found well at any rate they
picked China to do this study because in
one Province henan Province in China
they have the highest rate of cancer in
the whole world they took 29,000 people
for 5 years in this study and what they
did was give them different vitamins and
minerals at Double the recommended daily
allowance for Americans now that's a
trivial amount for instance they use
vitamin C for one group and of course
the um RDA recommended daily allowance
for vitamin C is 60 milligrams double
that going to be 120 milligrams you
can't go into a health food store and
find a vitamin C tablet or capsule for
less than 500 milligrams for an adult of
course lonus Pauling the gentleman with
two Nobel prizes says if you want to
prevent and treat cancer with vitamin C
you got to use 10,000 milligrams a day
well all the doctors who used to argue
with him back 35 years ago were all dead
and today Lon Pauling still 9 4 and he
works 14 hours a day 7 days a week on
his Ranch in the Big Sir in California
and teaches at the University of
California San Francisco so you have to
make up your choice whether you're going
to listen to the Dead Doctors or lonus
Pauling your
choice okay vitamin C dou the RDA
nothing happened vitamin A dou the RDA
nothing happened zinc riboflavin the
trace mineral mum n nothing happened in
one group they got a major benefit in
this group they got three nutrients at
one time they got vitamin E they got
beta katene and the trace mineral
selenium that those three were at Double
the RDA and if you get a half a percent
benefit in any nutritional or
pharmaceutical experiment you've made a
major Improvement in Humanity's life and
so these articles get published so I
want you to remember that statistic a
half a percent is major benefit well in
this group that received the vitamin E
beta carotene and selenium for 5 years
deaths from all causes were reduced by
9% almost 10 out of every hundred or one
out of every 10 who were going to die in
that 5 Years From Any cause
survived then cancers all cancers 133%
survived who would have died without
those three
nutrients so 13 out of 100 lived who
would have died and then the type of
cancer that was most prevalent in henan
Province stomach and esophageal cancer
21% lived who would have died 21 out of
100 lived now to me those are
significant numbers and your physician
for the number two cause of death in
America should have sent every one of
you a photocopy of that at least giv you
information even if he didn't want to
give you the advice give you the
information let you make up your own
mind well here's one I think is funny on
one hand and on the other side it tells
you the attitude of Physicians this has
to do with arthritis it was in um
September 24th 1993 that it was released
again it was from the havit medical
school and the Baston VA Hospital how
many of you in here have ever been to a
VA Hospital anybody in this room okay
good well you know the people who' have
been to a VA Hospital you have two
opportunities to give your life for your
country once on the field of battle and
the others in the VA Hospital
right well at any rate the title of the
release was chicken protein hals the
swelling and pain of arthritis in a
patient trial and what they did they
took people who failed to respond in any
way to medical treatment for arthritis
these people got gold shots mesot
trexate they got aspirin prazone
cortisone everything else you can think
of physical therapy and the only thing
left for them was joint replacement
surgery okay now before Harvard Medical
School the VA hospital was going to give
it to them they said look we looking for
some people who are willing to suffer
for 90 more days just 3 months because
they want to try something a short-term
experiment and they got 29 volunteers
and what they did for those 29
volunteers who failed to respond in any
way to medical treatment for arthritis
was they gave them a heaping teaspoon
full of groundup dried chicken cartilage
in their orange juice every morning just
a heaping teaspoon of ground up chicken
cartilage and in 10 days according to
Harvard Medical School all the pain and
inflammation was gone these are people
who didn't respond in any way to medical
treatment in 30 days they could open up
a new pickle jar that never been opened
and 90 days 3 months they had maximum
return of
function now here's the funny part the
funny part comes by a statement of the
guy who was the director of that study
from Harvard Medical School and here's
what he said quote listen to the words
are very important quote after three
months it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote because it worked
chicken cartilage had become a
[Music]
drug you can see he's think about patent
numbers and his eyes are rolling around
with 300 bucks a capsule 20 patients and
you can just see him calculating
right that means if you go to Kentucky
Fried Chicken and you buy a bucket of
chicken throw away the skin and the meat
and eat the ends off the bones you're
practicing medicine without a
license and if you go to a Kentucky
Fried Chicken in the middle of the night
in the dark of the night and you go to
their dumpster and you root through
there and you collect two five gallon
feed buckets full of chicken bones and
you take them home with a hammer and you
pound off the ends of those bones and
dry your own cartilage in microwave you
know you're manufacturing a
pharmaceutical and the FDA is going to
put you in
jail well if that's a little messy for
you you don't want to pay those lawyer
fees you can go into any grocery store
and get some noox gelatin women know
about noxon because it's good for your
finger nails and your hair and your skin
it has the raw materials for chicken
cartilage has the raw material for your
cartilage it's made out of beef
cartilage and beef tendon and if you
take two of those little half oun
envelopes a day in your orange juice and
you take it with an ounce per 100 lb of
body weight of colloidal
minerals next time I come by here in 3
months you're going to run up on this
stage and hug me and kiss me if you got
arthritis how many you have ever heard
of Alzheimer's disease everybody's heard
about it today 50 years ago when I was a
little kid there's no such thing as
Alzheimer's disease it's a new disease
one of those things that just sort of
happened now it's a major disease one
out of every two people who reach age 70
get Alzheimer's dis is pretty scary well
we learned 50 years ago in the animal
industry how to prevent and cure in the
early stages Alzheimer's disease and
livestock can you imagine how much a
farmer would lose if the pigs were all
laying there scratching their head
saying why am I
here where is the feed box because if
they're not gaining a couple of pounds a
day you're losing money right so we
learned in the agricultural industry how
to prevent in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease and we do it with
high doses of vitamin E and low intakes
of vegetable oil you you say w like
that's crazy high doses of vitamin E
well you should have got a recall notice
from your doctor in July of 1992 because
the University of California I mean
we're talking about a sophisticated
research medical school here University
of California San Diego came out and
said vitamin E eases memory loss and
Alzheimer's victims now they're only 50
years behind on that from veterinary
medicine so he might be safer going to a
veterinarian then how many of you in
this room ever had a kidney stone
anybody in here ever get that kidney
stone okay I see a few in here what's
the first thing a doctor told you to
give up nutritionally when you got your
kidney stone give up calcium no Dairy no
Dairy none of those vitamin mineral
things with calcium in them because they
have the stupid naive ignorant belief
that's pretty intense they have the
stupid ignorant naive belief that the
calcium in your kidney stone comes from
the calcium you eat when in fact it
comes from your own bones when you have
a raging Calcium deficiency a raging
osteoporosis then you get kidney stones
we learned a thousand years ago in ring
in the agricultural industry if you
wanted to prevent kidney stones and
livestock you better give them more
calcium you better give them more
magnesium and more
Boron the reason is of course bulls and
rams male cattle and sheep have special
Anatomy when they get a kidney stone
they die they call water belly they die
when you and I get a kidney stone we
just wish we were dead but no farmer is
dumb enough to pay for the feed for an
animal and have it die before you can
either eat it or send it to Market so we
learned how to prevent those things well
you should have got a recall notice from
your doctor especially you people who've
had kidney stones your you're ologist
should have sent a notice to you this
was about 15 months ago March of 1993 it
says calcium limits kidney stone risk
and this is from the havid medical
school up in Baston by the way in a
study that turns conventional medical
wisdom on its head researchers have
found that people whose diets are rich
in calcium run a reduced risk of
developing kidney stones in a study of
more than 45,000 people that who are
ranked into five categories the group
that had the most calcium had no kidney
stones so it took them a thousand years
to catch up
now about 5 years ago when I started out
on this Crusade and started lecturing to
people all across America and I'm in one
time zone and the next and all over I
knew I was going to get crazy out there
uh doing this last year I was on the
road 300 days out of the Year 300 out of
365 days and so I decided I needed to
have a hobby that I could take with me
every time I get a little wacko I could
go in my room and do this Hobby and I'd
be okay you know be kind of like having
a little piece of home with me wherever
I went I wanted to have a hobby that
would uh uh help other people I didn't
want to collect baseball cards because I
like football and I didn't want to do
just crossword puzzles because good
mental exercise it wouldn't help anybody
else and um I couldn't take my compost
pile I like the garden and the hotels
don't like that you know so I decided I
was going to collect obituaries of
doctors and
[Music]
lawyers now as crazy as that sounds
remember I told you the doctors live to
an average age of 58 and we live to 75.5
and here's a group of people profession
who pontificate you and tell you well
this is what you need to do you need to
give up salt and uh no caffeine and you
need to not eat butter and eat margarine
and do all these crazy things and they
die at age 58 on the average and of
course all those people who live to be
120 to 140 they put a chunk of rock salt
in their tea every day and they drink 40
Cups of Tea a day 40 chunks of rock salt
and they cook with butter instead of
olive oil and they live to be 120 so who
are you going to believe the people who
live to be 58 or the people who live to
be 120 is your choice anyway got a few
of them here some of my favorites this
is Dr Stuart Cartwright aged 38 he
dropped dead in his home he was a family
practitioner of a ruptured aneurysm
that's a ballooning of an artery that's
a weakened artery because of the
fragmenting or the brittle condition of
the elastic fibers and arteries just
like when you hit a Chuck hole with your
car tire and you break the cords in
there and you get a
balloon he dropped dead like he was
poleaxed okay right in his home from a
ruptured a Artic aneurysm and we learned
in 19 19 oh I think it was uh
57 aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency we had a pilot project
250,000 turkeys and we made complete
food pellets where you put all the 90
nutrients in there and in the first 13
weeks fully half of those turkeys died
125,000 of them farmers were out there
every morning picking them up by the
bushel basket they took them to the
state diagnostic labs and they autopsy
and they found out that they all had
died from a ruptured a Artic aneurysm so
they doubl the amount of copper in there
and the next year they tried to raise
500,000 turkeys and they didn't lose a
single turkey from a ruptured Artic
aneurysm and they ran that experiment in
mice and rats and rabbits and dogs and
cats and uh calves and sheep and pigs
and whatnot and guess what they found
out that there's a whole series of
diseases that are caused by a copper
deficiency gray hair is the first sign
when you start getting gray hair
regardless of your age you got a copper
deficiency you get skin wrinkles because
the elastic fibers in your skin are
going those little crows feet around
your eyes and facial and body skin
wrinkles you look like you're a little
prune drying up
okay then of course there's the um uh
varicose veins varicose veins that's
caused by an elastic fiber breakdown
then of course parts of your body begin
to Sag under your arms your breast your
bellies your legs all this stuff starts
sagging and you can go to a cosmetic
surgeon or plastic surgeon if you want
but it's a lot cheaper and a lot more
effective and a lot safer if you just
take some copper okay well Dr cartright
may have had a medical degree but he
didn't have expensive so he died of
something that even a turkey Wouldn't
Die from and here's one this fellow he
was a doctor's doctor Dr Martin Carter
he almost made it he died at age
57 um he got his medical degree from
havit medical school and his PhD in
medicine from Yale of course um he was
autopsied by the best because he was a
doctor's doctor he said quote the cause
of death was a ruptured a Artic aneurism
said Dr Jules HS the Rockefeller
University Hospital unquote what did he
die from copper deficiency see he didn't
have expensive
either then here's an attorney she was
so famous she was from Detroit age 44
Ellen Joyce alter uh she was in the New
York Times obituary she made the big
time and uh of course she probably had
steel buns because she belonged to one
of those private health clubs all these
gals want steel buns you know doing
their little
exercises but she didn't have expensive
urine because she died of a ruptured
cerebral
aneurysm when they don't do an autopsy
the symptoms could be called a stroke or
uh subdural Hemorrhage but very
frequently they're caused by a ruptured
aneurysm which is a copper deficiency
she didn't have expensive urine how many
of you here have ever heard of a guy by
the name of steuart burger Stuart Berger
he he wrote five best-selling books on
health and diets and nutrition uh he got
his medical degree from tus medical
school which is a very fine medical
school in Boston not too far away from
uh Harvard Medical School and the books
he wrote included the Southampton diet
for weight loss he wrote Forever Young
20 years younger and 20 weeks and how to
be your own nutritionist and he died at
age
40 how'd you like to follow his dietary
practices he died at age 40 of
cardiomyopathy which is a selenium
deficiency the same cause as white
muscle disease or or stiff lamb disease
and any farmer can go to a feed store
and get selenium pellets or selenium
injections things like celotto and bzy
and so forth and Dr Stuart Burger a guy
who wrote five best-selling books on
nutrition died of a nutritional
deficiency he didn't have expensive
urine now you can prevent totally
prevent cardiomyopathy for 10 cents a
day and if we don't do it we're
malignant dumb I like to call it you're
malignant dumb if you don't take in 10
cents a day worth of selenium it's a
waste of your life that's one of those
landmines you can avoid the medical
treatment of choice for cardiomiopathy
as a heart transplant cost
$750,000 I want you to thank think about
that they get the heart free from a
donor they get the blood free for the
surgery from the relatives they use
$2.50 worth of suure
material and they charged
$750,000 for that procedure now 6 months
ago in La when they had the earthquake
they're putting people in jail for 60
and 90 days for price gouging for
selling these terrified people a gallon
of water for
$4 they put him in jail for price
gouging for selling him a gallon of
water for four bucks now to me that's
Entre ruralism you know that's being in
business for yourself if you had a a way
to distill water and make water and you
had a car and you could get in there and
sell those people a gallon of water for
4 bucks hey more power to you because if
you go to a 7-Eleven and buy a quart of
eon water it's
$129 so four of those quarts is a five
bucks but p is a disease that farmers
know about uh in horses it's called
cribbing when they chew on the feed bunk
the wooden feed bunk you know you better
give them some minerals otherwise
they're going to eat that feed bunk also
uh in cattle very cattle especially
they're losing lots of minerals through
their milk all the time intensive
milking you'll see them picking up big
rocks in the creek and chewing on them
or they'll chew on Bob wire or maybe
you'll see them walking down through a
path with a deer bone in their mouth or
something or a shingle that's called
Pica and a good farmer husbandry man
knows you better give them some minerals
otherwise they're going to eat the barn
or something in human beings we see this
at funny times pregnant women are
notorious for Pica uh in the middle of
the night they'll elbow their husband
and say Hey you better get up I want
some uh pickles and ice cream they're
crazy cing minerals because that fetus
is pulling minerals out of their body
they need some more minerals and so it's
it's recognized as a craving for things
like sweets and salt and so forth we see
this in pregnant women I used to have
people come to my practice and they say
do do I need to go see a shrink I said
why is that well I wake up in the middle
of the night and I go outside with a
spoon and I eat dirt and no that's okay
just make sure it's clean
dirt then they say my my kid sits there
with a kitty litter box between his legs
and has a spoon and he's eating that
stuff out of the kitty litter box
and then in housing projects little kids
eat lead paint off the walls and they
get lead poison get learning
disabilities and Bone problems and
anemia and we're good so we spend $5
million to scrape the lead paint off of
there and repaint it with latex paint
and all we have to do is give those kids
10 cents a day worth of minerals and be
better for them and save us 5 million
bucks it's your tax money and if we
allow them to throw them away those
dollars is kind of interesting any
rate if you have a selenium deficiency
and you don't want to wait until you get
cardiopathy and drop dead from a heart
attack to recognize it if you look on
your hands and look in the mirror in
your face if you have liver spots or age
spots and I see quite a few from
here you have an early selenium
deficiency that's called free radical
damage and fortunately for you if you
recognize that and you start taking in
some colloidal selenium in four to six
months those will all go away you'll
reverse that in four to six months and
when they go away on the outside they're
going away on the inside your brain and
your heart and your liver and your
kidneys
and if you have low blood sugar how many
in this room have low blood sugar
anybody in here have low blood sugar
okay about 10% how many you ever seen a
hyperactive kid who gets on
sugar okay about everybody in the
room people who have sugar problems are
like alcoholics there's good ones and
bad ones you know the good alcoholics
are one when they get two drinks they
just go off in a corner and go to sleep
right same way with somebody with low
blood sugar they eat a big meal or they
eat a piece of pie 3 hours later they
clunk out and go to sleep then there's
bad alcoholics they the that gets two
drinks in them and they get violent and
raged and they want to fight everybody
they punch holes in the wall you know
big Brave fellows and they kick their
wife and kick the dog and take the
chainsaw and cut their neighbor's tree
down and all these wild things and drive
Reckless down the roads and kill people
those are the bad drunks well people who
have blood sugar problems there's bad
blood sugar people too they a little
crazy okay I don't know how many of you
remember the twinkie
defense right remember when somebody
murdered two people and he claimed he
ate a Twinkie 3 hours before he murdered
them so they let him on because he got
temporarily insane every time he ate
sugar now don't any of you try
that well chromium and vadium deficiency
will result in the sugar problems low
blood sugar and if you let it go on for
any length of time you develop diabetes
chromium and vadium then a tin
deficiency the early symptoms of a tin
deficiency are male pattern baldness I
see a lot of tin deficiency in this room
yes and if you let it go on for any
length of time you get deafness
then there's a boron deficiency and you
gal should know about boron because it
helps you keep the calcium you take in
in your bones so you don't get
osteoporosis
Boron also it helps you make estrogen it
helps you fellas make testosterone if
you don't take in enough Boron you
ladies are going to suffer miserably
going through
menopause okay you're going to have all
those terrible symptoms you fellas don't
get enough Boron can't make testosterone
you won't know whether to lead or follow
on the Dance Floor
you're going to be
confused she's saying he's got a boron
deficiency then in laboratory oh I
should tell you too we said this on the
show today those of you may not have
heard it some of you didn't hear the
whole show the first symptoms of a zinc
deficiency is you lose your sense of
smell and your taste you say oh you know
food just doesn't taste good anymore and
you don't have a cold or anything like
that and you say your wife says well
aren't you excited about dinner I spent
the whole day in the kitchen cooking he
said well I didn't smell anything when I
walked in you know he's got a zinc
deficiency in laboratory animals there's
some seven rare Earths these rare Earths
or trace minerals you need in lesser
amounts than you need trace minerals and
they actually double the lifespan of
laboratory animals they've not been
proven in humans yet but I'm not going
to wait 500 years for doctors to approve
it they're still arguing over vitamin C
and calcium right so I'm just going to
do it didn't kill any laboratory animals
just doubles her life and it's not a
drug these rare Earths are called lanum
PR daium neodium samarium europium ubium
and
thulium there must be a reason why
they're named after Old Testament cities
well remember I told you we needed 90
nutrients we need 60 minerals we need 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids and
three essential fatty
acids and of course we're lucky in that
plants as a group can make most vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids plants can
do that because they just take carbon
out of the air and make carbon chains to
make vitamins amino acids and fatty
acids but you have to eat 15 to 25
different plants a day in the right
combinations to make this happen
theoretically it's possible but most
Americans don't do it the average
American thinks if they eat some potato
buds out of a Betty Crocker box or
eating a vegetable okay so you got to be
careful what you're considering a
vegetable then of course people want to
do right by their doctor and they eat
lowfat turkey breast and they put a half
a jar of mayonnaise on there and they
put it between two slices of Wonder
styrofoam bread remember that stuff you
can insulate your house with with and
put in your shoes when you get a hole in
shoe I remember when I was a kid 50
years ago it was a lot of fun because we
have Wonderbread we didn't have TVs back
then on the farm we didn't even have
dryers that went round and round so the
only thing you could do in the winter
time was sit in the kitchen and wand at
a loaf of Wonderbread and had the blue
and red and green yellow balloons on
there and if you read the label as many
times as I do you know it said things
like helps build bodies at 12 ways and
about 15 years later the FDA made him
change it to help build your body eight
ways now if you go to the store and look
at Wonderbread rappers it just says
Wonderbread so it kind of gives you a
clue so even though this is
theoretically possible is not likely to
happen that you're going to get your
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids in
proper proportions from your diet and so
if your life is as valuable to you as
mine is to me and my children's and my
grandchildren's is to me I would make
sure that I take in all my vitamins and
amino acids and fatty acids because I
guarantee you won't make it to 120 to 4y
if you don't you're just not going to do
it now minerals are another story we
have a tragic story when it comes to
minerals because plants cannot make
minerals in any way shape or form and if
they're not in the soil anymore they're
not in our
plants we have for you when you leave a
free copy of a summary of US Senate
document 264 US Senate document 264 is
from the 74th Congress second session
and it says that our farm soils and our
rain soils are depleted of minerals and
the crops the grains the fruits and the
vegetables and the nuts that are grown
on these depleted farm and Rain soils
are minerally deficient and the people
who eat them get mineral deficiency
diseases and the only way to prevent and
cure them is with mineral supplements as
US Senate document 264 74th Congress
second session it was written and
printed by the US Congress in
1936 58 years ago you think it's gotten
any better no it has not gotten any
better it's only gotten worse and the
reason is if you guys do what we did and
people continue to do is we put NPK on
our land nitrogen phosphorus potassium
and you see it as these three numbers
and many combinations of of um ratios
and these represent percentages of these
three nutrients nitrogen phosphorus
potassium and those of you who don't
have any experience on farms the reason
why we do this is farmers get paid for
tons and bushels there's no subsidy that
encourages people to put 60 minerals
back in the soil you get paid for tons
and bushels and for 40 bucks an acre you
can get the maximum yield in tons and
bushels it only takes 5 to 10 years to
deplete the land of minerals cuz every
time you harvest a crop those plants
pull minerals out of the soil many
pounds per acre every time you haul a
crop out so soon those minerals are gone
and if you only put back in three and
you take out 60 it's like a checking
account if you only put three bucks in
your checking account every month and
write checks for 60 what's going to
happen to your checks boing boing boing
they bounce exactly well I can tell you
that our health is bouncing right now to
the tune of $1.2 trillion a year because
there's no more minerals left in our
soil it's our responsibility each and
every one of us to be responsible for
our health and consciously take in these
minerals I have a lot of people ask me
what did these people do thousands of
years ago they didn't even have
commercial fertilizers what did they do
these societies that had long-lived
people and whatnot but I want you to
think about the Egyptians the
Chinese uh people from India that lived
around these Great Rivers the Nile River
the Ganges River um the yo river in
China and what used to happen was every
year or so would flood just like it did
here in Northern Missouri last year and
every time it flooded guess what would
happen it would bring silt or rock dust
from Mountains from 500 or thousand
miles away and those people would pray
to every God they had the water God the
sky God the wind God The Rock
God to flood we pray don't flood they
used to pray to flood because they had
their floods during the winter time and
would put silt and minerals back in the
soil and their grain was very valuable
King Philip who's the father of uh
Alexander the Great married the
12-year-old child queen of Egypt
Cleopatra she didn't look like Elizabeth
Taylor all made up and beautiful
costumes she was a little flatchested
teeny bopper not very sexy but Philip
married her because she controlled the
best wheat in the world and if he wanted
his Macedonian army to conquer the world
through his son Alexander the Great he
needed the best wheat in the world so he
could March 20 hours a day fight for six
hours and win if they used the wheat
from the depleted soils and grease they
couldn't go
20 minutes without saying mommy pick me
up can you imagine these big Greek
soldiers Oh my legs hurt pick me
up and so they knew the best place to
get wheat was from
Egypt it was those floods that gave them
those minerals and all those cultures
that came up with all the great art and
all the great technology came from those
PE places because they had more
intelligence because they had more
nutrition more minerals I heard somebody
say very good you're getting the picture
well what I'm going to do here is I'm
just going to pick out a couple of
minerals
just a couple of them so you get the
idea it applies to all of them let's
just pick out a common one like calcium
everybody knows about calcium Calcium
deficiency will result in something like
147 different diseases they're just
different names they're named after
people like Bell's paly Bell's paly is
you know everybody knows about that one
side of your face sags it's not a true
stroke it just affects your facial
muscles it's caused by Calcium
deficiency we'll talk about in a little
bit but everybody knows about this one
osteoporosis
it's the number 10 killer of adults
United States it's very expensive it
costs you $35,000 each for each hip to
replace it's okay it's free insurance or
Medicare or Hillary will pay for it cost
you $70,000 for both hips as expensive
as it is and the number 10 killer
remember Mrs ski from Radford Virginia
aged 115 years of age she died of
complications of a fall we don't have
osteoporosis and animals and it's
because of farmers we don't have
osteoporosis and animals goes like this
you have a a pasture with 100 cows in it
and this year you didn't have any calves
you can't repay your operating loan
you're in trouble right because you paid
for the feed and the vet bill and mowed
the pasture and fertiliz and maintain
the fence and fed the cows and all this
that and the other you don't have any
cash you can't pay back the oper
operating load and make any money so you
call the vet out and you say do I get
rid of these cows what happened here and
he examines the cows he says nothing
wrong with them says let me look at the
bull he say aha here's your problem that
bull has osteoporosis of both hips can't
breed the cows didn't have any calves he
says I'll tell you what though he says
you give me $70,000 he says I'll put two
new hips in that bull and next year
you'll have some calves well the first
thing that farmer says is stand back doc
boom he blows that bull away with a deer
rifle and well the kids are grinding the
kid the well the kids are grinding the
bull up with um a grinder and cutting
roast and steaks off that bull the
farmer is chewing on a strong saying now
Doc pushes ston up a little bit and he
says you know he says U you know I
wasn't going to pay you $7 for that old
bull he says I can get a new bull every
year for 70 years for that he says but
every once in a while I get a bull that
throws good calves I'd like to keep them
is there any way I can prevent that
osteoporosis thing for happen to a good
bull he says well yeah he says if you'll
give a bull calf 10 cents worth of
calcium every day after he's weaned
he'll never get osteoporosis F wait a
minute doc you mean if I give that bull
10 cents a day worth of calcium from the
time he's wean I can prevent a
$70,000 disaster oh yeah that's that
simple he says you mean all I have to do
is give up a half a cup of coffee a day
to do that
he says yeah that's it he says I choose
that one he say I'll give up the half a
cup of coffee and that's what we have to
think like okay then there's receding
gums dentist and periodontist will tell
you that if you want to prevent and cure
receding gums you better floss and brush
after every meal if you believe that
works I have some oceanfront property in
Montana to sell you if you all know your
geography you know that doesn't work now
as a veterinarian I've seen hundreds of
thousands of animals of all kinds mice
rat cats rabbits dogs cats sheep pigs
horses lions and tigers and bears and
they don't get receding gums and they
don't floss now they do get funky breath
but they don't get receding gums boy if
you want to smell something you just let
a camel breathe on you
boy well the reason we don't have
receding gums and livestock is because
we've dealt with the osteoporosis
problem receding gums is not a
deficiency of flossing it's in fact
osteoporosis of the jaw bones and the
facial bone so if you have gingivitis or
receding gums you have advanced
osteoporosis those bones around your
teeth are melting away little bit by a
little bit every day and if you take
your teeth out at night and put them in
a glass next to your bed and that fizzy
stuff you have major advanced
osteoporosis because all your bone has
melted away okay then there's
arthritis we talked about that a little
bit earlier remember the chicken Cartage
or the nox gelatin 85% of all arthritis
is caused by osteoporosis to the Joint
ends of the bones you're talking about
degenerative arthritis osteoarthritis
sciatica lumbago rheumatism all those
sorts of things um they're caused by
osteoporosis of the joint ends of the
bones I want you to think about
something for a minute if you don't take
a pain reliever or or an
anti-inflammatory for that arthritis
let's say you get arthritis of the hips
you're going to kind of favor that a
little bit aren't you you're going to
get a cane or a walker or crutches
you're going to favor it and so you
don't put any weight on
it I want you to think about that for
just a second because then I want you to
think about driving your tractor in a
field or you're driving a Mercedes down
the highway either one doesn't matter
whichever you love more and um let's say
you didn't put the nut on that oil pan
real tight and all the oil drained out
and that light on the dashboard comes on
and says I'm getting hot you better give
me some oil and that light irritates you
so you stop you open up the hood you get
your clippers out you know your fence
Clippers and you clip the the wire to
that light and you close the hood and
you just keep
driving would you do that to your
tractor or your Mercedes no you wouldn't
but we take those pain relievers for
arthritis and we go out there and square
dance and do the Texas step and do our F
mile walks and our aerobics that pill
Works real good doc because it killed my
pain and you're just wearing that thing
off faster and
faster then your doctor is really going
to get rich because you need joint
replacement
surgery then there's hypertension this
is one of my favorites I'll put a star
over
here hypertension is high blood pressure
what's the first nutritional thing that
a doctor will tell you to give up
nutritionally when you get high blood
pressure give up salt everybody knows
that one that's been ingrained in our
head well they must think we're dumber
than cows because what's the first thing
you put out for your livestock it's
about that big a salt block no farmer is
going to be economically viable if you
don't put a salt block out for your
livestock they're going to die kind your
Veterinary bills are going to go crazy
but we're supposed to believe that we
don't need salt you can get everything
you need out of your lettuce and your
whole wheat bread and stuff like that
well don't believe that one either if
you believe that I got some more ocean
front property in Montana for you
remember those long liveed people put a
big chunk of rock salt the size of a big
black concord grape in every cup of tea
and they drink about 40 Cups of Tea a
day cuz they live at high altitudes
where it's very dry they have to keep
hydrated and they put
butter in their tea they put two Pats of
butter and a chunk of rock salt they
don't put the pink stuff or the blue
stuff or skin milk or what does they
call it uh creora or whatever it
is okay guess guess what the doctors who
live to be 58 tell you no salt no butter
the people who live to be 120 they put
in butter and salt so you got to make
some choices well they took $30 million
of your tax money and two years ago
after a 20- year study they came out and
said that they took 5,000 people with
high blood pressure they took them off
their medication and put them on a
reduced salt diet a restricted salt diet
and they all died no big surprise but
somebody got a PhD degree and everybody
was happy
right but when they looked at this
results they said that oh only 99 7% of
the people didn't get any results from
that before they died 0.3% did get some
result dropped their blood pressure one
point before they died by restricting
their salt so the referees who judged
that article said oh doesn't matter you
might as well let high blood pressure
patients eat salted peanuts and deal
pickles and salt their food to taste
because it doesn't matter in fact
worrying about the salt is more stress
than taking the salt then they had a
control group with 5,000 people with
high blood pressure and they doubled
their RDA of calcium and they stopped
the experiment in 6 weeks
because 85% of them were cured of their
high blood pressure just by doubling
their calcium intake now they didn't
cold turkey stop their high blood
pressure medication but what they did
was they went to the doctor and says you
don't need this medication anymore what
are you doing well I'm on this
experiment where I double my calcium
intake anybody get a recall notice from
your doctor saying it's okay to Salt
your food to taste and please do double
your calcium intake anybody get that not
a single one that's very
interesting then of course there's
insomnia that's where you roll around
all night you get your you wake up in
the morning you're more tired when you
went to bed that's insomnia of course
doctors have two treatments for that
they have hion which is a sleeping pill
and they have barbituates they kill
about 10,000 people a year with
overdoses of those things but that's
okay it's a prescription and they're
watching out for us and remember
remember uh George Bush when he went to
Japan they gave him some helon so he
could sleep on the way to Japan because
of the time difference and when he woke
up one of the the side effects of helon
is nausey and vomiting
I don't know how you say it in Japanese
but it was very dramatic on world TV
right not very
presidential and so I'm sure that's why
he lost the election because he puked
over that Japanese
Ambassador and then of course there's
kidney
stones and then there's bone spurs heel
spurs and calcium deposits again
Physicians will tell you the first thing
to give up nutritionally is calcium and
dairy because they have this foolish
belief the stupid belief the ignorant
belief that the calcium in kidney stones
bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits come from uh your diet when
instead it only comes from your bones
when you have a raging osteoporosis and
when you get these things you need more
calcium not less then there's cramps and
Twitches you wake up in the middle of
the night and your foot is all cramped
up around your neck and you say Lord
take me from the knee down I'm not going
to make it till morning we've all
experienced that that's very
common then there's PMS premenstrual
syndrome you know the emotional and
physical stuff the medical treatment of
choice for PMS is what we call a
hysterical ectomy it's been shortened to
hysterctomy that's a 100- year old
treatment that doctors do about 285,000
unnecessary hysterical ectomies a year
but it makes Mercedes payments so they
do them even the AMA said they're
unnecessary but they don't take their
licenses away and people keep going to
them you imagine poor woman in her 30s
she says doc you got to do something
every time I go out to hang out the
clothes my neighbors kids run down the
basement screaming witch my own kids
think I'm crazy my husband's leaving me
I'm going lose my job you got to do
something well the University of
California San Diego came out three
years ago now and said if you just
double the RDA of calcium intake you get
rid of 85% of the emotional and physical
symptoms of PMs and when that came out
there were huge lines around the health
food stores around the blocks and people
had sleeping bags cuz they closed before
they all got their calcium and every
person in line was a
man they were there for their daughters
and their girlfriends and their wives
and things like
that okay and lastly is low back pain
85% of Americans get low back pain
whether you work on a computer or you
unload hay or you drive big trucks
doesn't matter low back is a big problem
low back is just osteoporosis of the
vertebrae whether you have a disc
problem or whatnot because if your disc
doesn't have anything to hold on to your
vertebrae melted away what's going to
happen to the disc especially if you
have a copper deficiency because they're
made out of elastic fibers they go like
a water balloon with a lot of pressure
on them well I just want you to look at
this quickly before we do the last
mineral low back you go to an orthopedic
surgeon or rheumatologist you might get
a um muscle relaxant you might get
valium and a muscle relaxant you get a
laminectomy you get your vertebrae fuse
you might get a disc operation they
don't tell you 75% of the time you'll
never be the name again right PMS you go
to your
OBGYN you can um go to an internist you
can go to a family counselor a shrink or
divorce attorney cramps and Twitches you
go to a neurologist you go to a sports
medicine doctor an internist bone spurs
heel spurs calcium deposits you go to a
rheumatologist an orthopedic surgeon or
a podiatrist kidney stones you go to a
urologist or an internist or a surgeon
insomnia you go to a shrink or a um
Sleep Clinic or an internist
hypertension you go to a Cardiologist an
intern
or a surgeon arthritis a rheumatologist
a orthopedic surgeon or an internist
receding gums you go to a dentist or
periodontist osteoporosis you go to all
those Health Specialists including a tum
salesman for nothing more than a Calcium
deficiency it cost you 10 cents a day to
deal with now on the average because
Americans have insurance and we have
Medicare and Medicaid we spend on the
average $225,000 to
$250,000 and we undergo 5 to 10 surgical
procedures a
year for a Calcium deficiency and we beg
the doctors to do it we beg the doctors
to do
it well it's our choice the last one
I'll share with you is diabetes
everybody's touched by diabetes it's the
number three cause of death in adults in
the United
States number three cause of death and
it has terrible complications and side
effects diabetes
the side effects include blindness of
many
kinds then there's a kidney failure with
dialysis and kidney transplant there's
cardiovascular disease of all kinds and
of course that contributes the number
one cause of death which is the number
one cause of death uh then there is
amputations everybody ought to have one
of those because they're totally paid
for in your health thing because they
assume that you're not just going to get
one because you want to get everything
on your health benefits and then you
shorten your life
because you have a shorter life lifespan
than someone who doesn't have diabetes
now we learned in
1957 in the animal industry that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with two
trace
minerals that's pretty profound
statement that we could prevent and cure
diabetes with two trace minerals in 1957
and animals it was published in
Federation proceedings which is the
official Journal of the American Science
the National Institutes of Health the
official monthly Journal was August
1957 well the two trace minerals that
you can get to prevent and cure this are
chromium and vadium vadium alone
according to the University of Vancouver
British Columbia Medical School vadium
alone will replace
insulin in addult onset diabetics which
represent 85% of all diabetics of course
it can't quit their insulin cold turkey
they got to gradually wean off of it
takes four to six months for most people
to slowly wean off of insulin if they're
taking in adequate amounts of chromium
and vadium I've seen it work on hundreds
and hundreds of people now to me this is
Criminal because you right to uh Hills
packing company that makes s do dog food
right over here in toeka Kansas I don't
know if I'm pointing West but that way
okay they're all saying that
way TOA Kansas they manufacture Science
Diet dog food and other Science Diet
product Hightech foods for Animals if
you write them and say how many minerals
exactly is in Science Diet for dog food
they'll write you back and say there's
40 minerals you write checkerboard
Square in St Louis R and perian say just
how many minerals are in your rat
pellets for laboratory rats and those
say there's 28
minerals I'll give anybody in this room
a crisp new $100 bill if you can find me
a human infant formula in a grocery
store that has more than 11 so our dogs
get 4y minerals that's what Mike Murphy
was saying his dog never seems to get
sick CU he's getting this canned dog
food with all these vitamins and
minerals in there so our dogs get 40
minerals our rats get 28 minerals and
our human infants get 11 is that fair no
that's called
fraud doesn't matter if you're talking
about SMA Similac Isomil proy B fact
that's why they call Similac Similac cuz
it lacks
[Applause]
everything okay if I've convinced you
that you have to consciously take in all
the minerals yourself that you can't
depend on your food and certainly you
can't depend on anything that's boxed or
packaged or bottled there's three types
of minerals that you have to be
concerned about one is metallic minerals
and metallic minerals are essentially
groundup rocks metallic minerals are
things like oyster shell egg shell
Dolomite Limestone uh calcium carbonate
Clays of various kinds Mount marinite
clay seabed minerals they're TS they're
only 8 to 12% absorbable When You Reach
age 35 to 40 it drops down to 3 to 5%
and I have to tell you a story here some
of you heard this on the show today I
ran into a guy at a meeting like this up
at Grand Rapids Michigan and this fell
owns a Port-A-Potty business you know
that's that green or blue colored ouse
man if we we' only had one of those back
when I was a kid we had these ones with
splinters you know in the in the wood
any rate um he said I see some one
something that that describes that in my
porta potty business I said what's that
he says well we take those things back
to the shop to clean them out with the
pressure hose he says we put a quarter
inch grid underneath them because kids
throw rocks and sticks and toys in there
and if we don't put a grid there it
blocks up the sewer system it cost us
thousands of dollars to fix it he says
every time we clean one of those out we
find hundreds of vitamin tablets
I said well how do you know their
vitamin tablets he says well it's really
easy he says right on the coating it
says thamm want a day
Centrum he says come here he takes me
out in the back of his shop and there's
this literal mountain of all these
vitamin pills he got out of his porta
potties that's because you can't absorb
metallic minerals if you read the labels
on those multiples they say your iron
comes in the form of iron oxide what is
iron oxide
rust you might as well just go out to an
old railroad track and take your butter
knife and scrape some of that rust off
and lick it and you're going to get your
iron supplement but that's what they're
giving you well I'll show you how bad it
is if you take something like calcium
lactate was which is a common metallic
mineral uh let's say it's a calcium tab
calcium lactate 1,000 milligrams if you
take two of those you're not getting
2,000 milligrams of calcium in fact I
have people all the time say well I took
lots of calcium doc I hear you on the
radio talking about calcium and
arthritis and I took 2,000 milligrams of
calcium a day didn't help my arthritis
in fact it got worse as so what kind of
calcium you taken they said calcium
lactate well there's your problem
because only 250 Mig of that is metallic
calcium so let's say you absorb 10% of
that then the other 750 milligrams is
lactose or milk
sugar so 10% of 250 is 25 so if you take
two of those tablets you're not getting
2,000 you're getting 50
milligrams so to get what you need you
need to take 90 of those tablets a day
you need to take 30 with each meal and
you got 59 more minerals to
go and there's those people who want to
do things naturally let's see if you can
do anything good with 10 lbs of spinach
and let's be fair let's see if you can
get a th000 milligrams of magnesium I
pick magnesium because in green leafy
vegetables you have a lot of magnesium
because of the chlorophyll right it's
part of the chlorophyll molecule and any
pound of anything you got 454 gram and
10 L pounds of spinach you got 4540 gram
of which most of that 97% is water let's
say you have 1 gram of chlorophyll in
that 10 pounds of spinach there's 50
milligrams of magnesium you got to
divide that into the Thousand you want
you get a factor of 20 which you
multiply times the 10 you have to eat
200 100 lbs of spinach you got 58 more
minerals to go okay so you got to be a
pretty big person to accomplish all this
even as big as I am you can't get it
done so I prefer to supplement rather
than do those
things then of course during the 60s the
agricultural industry came up with
teated minerals
chelated
minerals because Farmers aren't dumb
enough to pay for a dollar of something
that goes into an animal's mouth and
have 99 Cents come out in the manure so
I have to really thank Farmers for being
that clever and chelated minerals are
just metallic minerals with an amino
acid or protein or enzyme wrapped around
the metal atom and increase the
absorbability to 40% then the hell food
industry jumped on that right away
because it was a major Improvement in
absorbability of minerals the most
efficient way to absorb minerals is the
collidal Farm colloidal
minerals are 98% absorbable 2 and 1 half
times more available than chelated
minerals and 10 times more available
than metallic minerals and they're very
interesting they're liquid they can only
be liquid can't be pills powders or uh
capsules they're very small particle
size are 7,000 times smaller than a red
blood cell and they're negatively
charged every particle is negatively
charged your intestinal lining is
positively charged so you actually have
an electrical or magnetic gradient that
concentrates these minerals around the
lining of your intestine these three
things together give you the 98%
absorbability now plants have a very
interesting part to play in colloidal
minerals remember we said that plants
cannot create minerals they're not in
the soil plants can't make them remember
that US Senate document 264 says they're
not in the soil anymore at any rate
metallic minerals are taken up by plants
when they're in the soil plants convert
them in their tissues to colloidal
minerals and this is how we store
minerals in our body this is how we use
minerals in our body this is how we
transport minerals from the storage
place to their site of use in the
colloidal form well our plants our crops
don't have much in the way of colloidal
minerals in them because we don't have
any metallic minerals in our
soil is this important well yeah these
long live cultures who live to be 120 to
140 they have certain common
denominators they all live in high
mountain Villages that are above 8,500
to 14,00 ft in elevation they all have
less than 2 inches of precipitation a
year they don't have any rain they don't
have any snow they don't have any
Dew okay very very dry places and guess
what they get all their drinking water
and all their irrigation water for their
crops from what we call glacial milk
glaciers in every one of those
communities grind up the parent rock of
those mountains about 4 inches a year
there's more than 60 to 72 minerals in
each one of those places the water that
comes out from underneath those glaciers
is not clear like Perry or Evon water or
Poland water or geyser water you take a
glass full of it up and hold it up it
looks like Jersey milk I mean it is
either yellow white or white blue it
looks like milk and is called in titty
Kaka see I got to say it again in titty
Kaka or Tibet they all call it glacial
milk cuz it looks like
milk and not only have they consumed it
drunk it and got 8 to 12% until they
were 35 to 40 then 3 to 5% absorption
for 2500 to 5,000 years depending on the
culture more importantly they have
irrigated with it year after year crop
after crop generation after generation
for 2500 to 5,000 years they have no
diabetes they have no heart disease no
high blood pressure no arthritis no
osteoporosis no cancer no cataracts no
glaucoma they have no birth
defects they have no jails full of drug
addicts they have no taxes they have no
doctors yet they live to be 120 to 140
without disease are these collidal
minerals important You Bet Your Life
they're important and every time you
don't take them in every day you're
chopping off a few hours or a few days
of your
life okay now most people are not going
to go to hanza or Tibet or titty
Kaka because we don't have Kenmore
kitchens there or even Saturn cars or TV
Changers uh Channel Changers or
electricity they don't have insulated
houses they don't have central heating
or air
conditioning but what they do have is
colloidal minerals now the only place
you can get these in the United States
is from a
prehistoric Valley in southern Utah that
according to geologist 75 million years
ago had 60 to 72 minerals in the walls
and the floor of that Valley and those
trees and the grasses in that Valley and
that Forest took up all the metallic
minerals and made colloidal minerals in
their tissues about that time there was
a volcanic eruption which inomed that
Valley with a thin layer of mud and um
Ash not thick enough or heavy enough to
crush or pressurize this into oil or
coal it was very dry in here so it never
became fossilized or petrified okay
never became Rock today if you put a
shaft into this Valley it's still just
dried hay I I bucked a lot of hay bales
so I know what hay looks like and this
stuff is just hay it's 75 million year
old hay according to geologist you can
still see the grass and the leaves and
the twigs and the pine conbs and the
bark and so forth and we grind this
plant material up into a flour very
small particle size flour just like a
good wheat flour and for 3 to four weeks
we soak it and filtered spring water and
when it reaches a specific gravity of
3.0 is very
heavy it has 38 gram of this colloidal
mineral in it per quart or liter and by
actual analysis it has 60 colloidal
minerals in it
[Applause]
to discover how colloidal minerals can
improve your health and promote
longevity contact the person that shared
this tape with you